david beckham is just like the rest of
us well kind of the soccer legend was
spotted among thousands of well-wishers
lining up to say farewell to queen
elizabeth at westminster hall yeah david
told reporters and fans that he'd been
in line since 2 a.m london time and he's
still there 12 hours later cheryl yeah
so just like everyone else he's waiting
for his turn to pay respects and there
doesn't seem to be any special treatment
for big name celebrities like david
beckham and david explained to itv his
grandparents would have been there if
they were alive today so he was doing it
on their behalf take a look and we'll
see you next time have a great weekend i
grew up in a household
of royalists and i was brought up that
way so you know my if my grandparents
would have been here
today uh i know that they would have
wanted to be here so i'm here
on their behalf and on behalf of my
family and obviously just to celebrate
with everybody else here i don't want to
hold you up so we'll no i get told off
if i uh do you think we've really
understood what we have lost here
um i think it will take a long time to
to understand that because i think that
i think her majesty meant so much in so
many different ways you know i can speak
on on
on my behalf of you know the
the amount of times i was able to meet
her through my career and i was very
lucky you know i suspect over the years
there were many times you met her at her
late majesty i just wondered if there
were any anecdote stories that you just
remember
you know i always say the same thing you
know i you know i was i was very lucky
probably the the most special moment for
me was when i received my obe you know
and to receive my obe i took my my
grandparents with me who were the ones
that really you know brought me up to be
a huge royalist and a fan of the royal
family so to have them there and then i
step up and obviously i had my wife
there as well um to step up to get my my
honor but then also her majesty
to to to ask a question and to talk and
you know i was i was so lucky that i was
able to have
a few moments like that um in my in my
life you know to to be around her
majesty because we can all see with the
love that has
has been shown how special she is and
how special she was and and the legacy
that she leaves behind